[Music] I
thought there was no problem with repeating the peaceful days
until that day.
Run away! They're coming towards us.
Dragon Seeker Kings Seeker, is
n't it? It's rumored that Eris's elite are all together.
Wow, I say yes.  Let's finish the report now.
My name is Nicola and I work at an inn in the village.
I think you're the Seeker who was used by the king. You're too
serious. I don't know if you
can be trusted or not. I was
surprised.  Sorry, it's okay. It's
not
me. What were you doing there? I wanted to
observe the dragon up close. What's wrong
? After all, you're just an ordinary person, so what should I do?
I can't work alone.  I'm not going to continue with you
guys.Okay, okay, I've
found a pattern, so
I'm telling you to check it out seriously.Nicola-san, go back to the village and
immediately return to the village and evacuate everyone.A
big dragon has attacked a village.  Niki,
run faster,
yes
Niko, I
can't let you die now
[Music]